Christianity is the world's most
populous religion followed by Islam but
we're Christians are in a minority
they're also the world's most persecuted
band from practicing their faith
imprisoned tortured driven away this
situation is not very good for Christian
people everywhere in the Middle East but
also the forests in Africa to is not
only the problem with fundamentalist
Muslim fundamentalist it is important to
strengthen the dialogue between
religions they made a start in
Parliament this week during a call to
action bringing together Christians to
share often harrowing experiences
Christians such as Helen burhan who fled
eritrea after several years incarcerated
in a shipping container where she was
tortured and Christian I love Muslims
but I have limit we must stand in our
face if it's costing us die ok we can
die but the next generation can stunt
event was held in the framework of EU
treaty provisions on interfaith dialogue
there should skilled nice pure the IANA
order the unreality on the good for a
lousy give get now so focused